今実は
始めそうですちょっと久しぶりに個人的なお悩み解決動画を取ろうと思います
僕の今の悩みはですね
何度見てもわかるんですけど
僕実はめっちゃ9設計なんですよそそ明るい中身だけ
日金銀
僕の悩みはねぇ
この
前髪ですよこれ今今日台風来て熱意なんですけど
前髪のこのクレックリフターこの
いやーなんか嫌なんですけどこういう免許
なにこのあ旅人みたいなわかるかな
俺はなんか
俺だけの
俺だけのものを探してみたいなこれの家なんですよ僕
是沢せてないですしこちら
うわぁいって面
ストレートかーわーレズる
メンズって書いてありますねすごくないこれがんこ
くせ毛をまっすぐ
簡単てレベル10分タイプということで
まあこれを使ったらこんなイケメンにはならないと思うんですけど
行為まあまっすぐの前髪が私はこのはが執拗に収めたいと思いもうスター持ったので
これ500円ぐらいで売ってたんですけどこんな安物で本当に速球へストレート玉買っ
てあげるかあげれるようになるかって言う
では行こう
これ何度別にーなんか批判とかしないで下さいに俺が病院でストレートパ
ストレートバームをかけたときにやってもらったんですけどまず
アイロンでまっすぐに住んですとりあえず
髪の毛
まっすぐにしたらなんかかかりやすいんような気がしました
これはをレス違うからねこれ俺のせいにしないでくださいね前になっても
病室の人は何かいつもこれだけまっすぐにしてたんで
これは多分効果的なんですよね
べきああ
どうもこれがいますと口にして
色を塗ったら入らなくてストレートパーマーの液を塗ったら
まあ客さんに台北台北
ベンベンになるようになると思うんだよ
酒ていきましょう
かぶっ
を
てるけど
うらしい
ふっ
はっはっは
逸材
にザーザーいい
うっっ
説明書がなぁ
ああああああああ
持っ
だだめだめだめ実は塗っておきましょう
a子はやばいやり食べなくなってきたう
まず五大いらんだて不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
ん